[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN WOOD: Room to Read started
a little bit by happenstance.
I never expected to quit
Microsoft to become a full-time
do-gooder--
full time education person.
But in 1998, when I was at
my seven year anniversary
with Microsoft, I decided
to take a long trip
to escape from the day
to day grind and meetings
and email and all that stuff.
And a good place
to escape really
is the Himalayas, because you're
just isolated from the day
to day reality.
I went to Nepal to do an 18 day
track in the Annapurna circuit.
And at the end of
my first day, I
met a local headmaster who had
a dilapidated little school
in the little village
of Bahundanda, Nepal.
He asked me if I wanted
to come do a quick tour,
and I thought this
would be a cool way
to see what's a local
school look like.
And like many schools
in the developing world,
it was simultaneously hopeful,
because 400 kids were showing
up, but it was also rather sad.
The physical infrastructure
is in horrible shape,
the classrooms are
terribly overcrowded,
they couldn't even afford desks.
And when the headmaster
showed me the library,
that was the most depressing
part of the visit,
because the library
was completely devoid
of children's books.
And I asked the headmaster why,
and he said, well, in Nepal,
we're too poor to afford
education for our kids.
But if we don't
get them educated,
we're going to
always remain poor.
And that struck me
as a cruelest irony--
that you could look at any
five-year-old or six-year-old
in the eyes and say,
literally, you've
lost the lottery of life, right?
By the very accident
where you were born
and where I were born,
we got a good education.
And it doesn't mean our
lives are easy or perfect,
but we've been given
that opportunity.
So these kids didn't
have the opportunity.
I thought, OK, I can
help this headmaster out.
He gave me a
homework assignment.
He said, perhaps, sir, you will
someday come back with books.
I eagerly agreed.
I shook his hand, and I said,
I'll see you within a year.
And I went back a year later
with 3,000 donated books
on the back of six donkeys,
and it was the happiest day
the kids had had,
because they'd never
seen brightly colored
children's books before.
So it was kind of
like this mosh pit--
this literacy palooza.
Kids were stage
diving onto the books.
Their eyes were bright,
and their smiles were wide.
It was a happy day
for me too, though,
because I realized that
there was something
a small amount of effort
and a small amount of money
would give these kids a chance
that their parents never
thought their kids would have.
And that was the genesis
of Room to Read, really.
That was good, but
let's not stop at one.
In a world of 770 million
illiterate people,
we've got to find a
way to do a lot more.
So that's where I
face the dilemma of,
do I keep doing this
as a hobby, or do I
quit Microsoft and make
it a full time thing
that I do 7/24 365?
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Before
we go to that piece
where you professionalized
it-- so you said you came back
with 7,000 books, you said?
JOHN WOOD: 3,000 books.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Did
you buy them yourself?
Was this donations?
This first year--
how did it go along?
JOHN WOOD: It was done
really as just a book
drive over the internet.
It was sending old-fashioned
emails out to people.
This is actually
before we really even
had widespread texting--
sending emails out to friends,
asking them to send books
to a couple collection
points we established
with friends in my parents'
garage in the state of Colorado
in the US.
And so many people when
they sent books to us,
they wrote us letters--
us me and my father and I,
because my 73-year-old father
had become my unpaid
right hand man.
He needed a retirement
project, and my mother
needed him to have a
retirement project.
And so many people
wrote us letters
to say, thank you
for doing this,
because I've traveled in Nepal,
and I've seen the poverty
and wanted to do
something about it.
But just giving money away
doesn't solve poverty.
Other people said, thanks for
doing this, but by the way,
I've traveled in Cambodia, where
the Khmer Rouge burned down
the schools and
burned the books.
Can you bring the program there?
So I just realized that so many
people got emotionally invested
in the idea that if you can
give a child in a poor country
the access to education that
they would not have otherwise
had, that that is something that
people can get excited about,
because it's a permanent
solution to poverty.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: OK.
I see.
So you're at this
point of 3,000 books.
You come back, they love it.
So what went through
your head then
about your career and
the choices you faced?
JOHN WOOD: I think leaving that
little village of Bahundanda
that day was very difficult.
Because the minute
I started walking away
from that village,
I was walking back
towards my normal life.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: So you hadn't
quit your job at that point?
JOHN WOOD: I hadn't.
I had just taken a week off.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Did you consider it?
Or was that--
JOHN WOOD: No, it was
premature to consider it.
But what happened
was the minute I
saw how much this meant to
the kids and their parents
and their teachers--
and then even other teachers
had tracked four, five, six
hours from other remote
villages to be there.
And they said, we heard there's
a man coming with books.
And then people would--
petition was the
word they used--
can may I petition you
to come to our school?
And so the challenge
I think I faced
going back to Microsoft to
where I was living in Beijing--
I was director of
business development
for the greater China region,
which is a very demanding role.
I thought about those
other headmasters,
and I thought about all the
schools I'd seen in Vietnam,
and I thought about what having
traveled through Cambodia
in 1994 post Khmer Rouge.
I thought, this is a really big
potential thing I could go do.
To be clear, I didn't make
enough money at Microsoft
to start a foundation.
I had made enough to
take a financial risk
and start a
cash-strapped NGO, but I
was going to have to be
reliant on public support
from the very beginning to
really get it scaled up.
But the thing I faced really--
I think what it came down to for
me is, I could keep doing this
as a hobby.
The problem is very simple--
hobbies don't scale,
organizations do.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: So
you're at this point.
You decided you wanted
to just full time.
But I think you
made a good point--
it wasn't also
your money, so you
need to come up with a
system and a model that
actually scales.
So what happened then?
What is the scaling then that
you managed over the years?
JOHN WOOD: Well, what the Room
to Read founding team did from
the very beginning was to
say, let's create and adopt
the project model, where anybody
anywhere can be connected
to a school-- it could be in
India, it could be in Tanzania,
it could be in Vietnam--
and know exactly where
their money went.
Too often with
charities, you don't
know where the money goes.
You don't know if it's being
used to get things done
or whether it's being used in
superfluous or wasteful ways.
So the number one thing we
said is adopt a school model
where our investors--
we don't call them donors.
Donor to me sounds too passive.
Our investors can get a
chance to connect directly
with a school.
We'll send them photos,
we'll send them video.
They can go visit it.
And that's really I think
what started to take off.
So Marc Andreessen was
one of our first investors
in Room to Read.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: The founder
of Netscape, a famous investor.
JOHN WOOD: Which is
ironic, because I
had been part of the
group at Microsoft
that was against Netscape, and
we were competing head to head.
But when I showed
Marc the model,
he just said, it's
unbelievable that you
can reach all these kids
with one simple library that
costs in inflation
adjusted dollars $20,000--
enough to actually set up
a library serving 400 kids.
So it's literally
$50 per child served.
So we started getting a lot
of Silicon Valley money.
Paul Haahr, who was an early
Google employee in the Bay
Area-- he and his wife
Susan got behind it,
and Don Valentine from
Sequoia Capital and his family
underwrote a lot
of the early work.
Because we just went to
a lot of the capitalists
and a lot of the tech
community to say,
this model means a little bit
of money can go a long ways.
And it's a chance--
I would never have enough
money to endow a building
at Northwestern University,
but gosh, you can actually
set up a program and bring a
literacy program and a library
program to a rural village
for a relatively small amount
of money.
So that was the first
part of the model.
The second part was really
having a very low overhead
model so we could prove
that the money was not
getting spent on overhead,
but it was going directly
to the program.
So we deploy about $0.84 on the
dollar directly to programs.
Charity Navigator, our rating
agency, gives us four stars.
We've had that
for 10 plus years.
And we take the financial
efficiency of it
very, very seriously.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Fantastic.
So talk a bit about the impact.
Because, obviously for us,
we have access to books.
But talk a bit about what it
means for somebody living there
with access to books.
What does this mean?
What is the impact of the
trajectory of their lives?
JOHN WOOD: So for us, we
started from very, very
humble beginnings.
And that first little
library in Bahundanda, Nepal
was opened in 1999.
I was in India two weeks ago,
and we actually celebrated
the 20,000th community that
Room to Read has reached with
our literacy programs
and our library program.
So it's scaled way
beyond my wildest dreams,
where we've launched now in
14 countries around the world,
primarily in
Southeast Asia, South
Asia, and sub-Saharan Africa.
And a really big
part of our model
is that really,
our leadership team
wants to run the
organization like a business.
In the early years,
I said, the heart
of Mother Teresa, the
scalability of Starbucks.
And that's really been our
model from the very beginning.
A lot of our leadership team are
what I call corporate refugees.
They've worked for a decade
plus in the for-profit sector.
They've learned
to run businesses.
They've learned to
scale businesses.
But a lot of our
leadership team--
they're ex-Goldman Sachs,
they're ex-Credit Suisse,
they're ex-Chiron, I'm not
the only ex-Microsoft person
to be employed,
they're ex-Deloitte.
And a lot of our leadership is
really built around the idea
that if you can run this like
a business and scale it--
and we have to
scale, because Google
is a classic example
of an organization that
sees opportunity in scale.
We don't think the line
should stop at the nonprofit.
We think nonprofit should
also scale as quickly.
Our moonshot is 770 million
people are illiterate.
Over 200 million kids
in the developing world
don't go to school every
day, and 2/3 of those
are girls and women.
So if we could solve those
three problems in our lifetime,
the effect on the world
would be just astronomical.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
So if I mentioned
I'm maybe a girl in
one of those villages,
what does it mean for
me to have those books?
I guess they have
teachers, right?
So it's material in a concept?
Talk a bit about the context.
How does this now play
a role in their lives?
I guess there's still more
context around it for them
to useful--
the books.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
So our goal is that every
community that we work in
on our literacy program,
for example-- the literacy
program's, of course, open
to both boys and girls.
It's important, we
think, that number one,
they have trained teachers
and trained librarians.
So that's a big part
of what Room to Read
does, because your
school's only going
to be as good as the
adults you have running it.
We have community co-investment,
so the communities
are required to
put resources in.
Quite often, it's sweat
equity-- it's labor--
to prove they value it.
The Ministry of
Education is required--
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
What do they do?
For example, you say sweat
labor-- what do they do,
for example?
JOHN WOOD: So I was in Sri
Lanka at one of our communities
we work in, and
parents had proudly
told me that they
had come and painted
both the inside and the
outside walls of the library.
One parent told me that he
had gone out and saved money
to buy a 100 pound bag of
cement as his contribution
to building this
library building.
Things like that where
our investor probably
made a little bit less effort
to write a large check--
they made a lot of
effort to earn the money,
but the effort put in
by these communities
is absolutely incredible.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: So you
create leverage and buy in,
and it really multiplies
actually the impact?
JOHN WOOD: Exactly.
It multiplies it,
and it also, I think,
makes the programs
much more sustainable.
Because if we just
send in a bunch
of well-meaning volunteers
to do a project,
and then those volunteers
leave, the community
doesn't feel that sense of
ownership or engagement.
So what we've always
been all about
is making sure that the
communities feel engaged enough
and that they value
the programs enough
that they will co-invest.
And then the
Ministry of Education
also co-invests in each project.
So when Room to Read brings our
literacy program to a village,
we require the
Ministry of Education
to provide the teachers
and the librarians
and to pay their ongoing salary.
Again, it's just
a way to make sure
that we're setting ourselves
up for long term success
by having a
tripartite agreement--
Room to Read, local community,
Ministry of Education.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: It's
fascinating to hear
how you actually started
with, in a sense, a very
simple idea--
bringing books.
But then you managed to
scale a lot of-- it's almost
like a business model, right?
It's not a business.
It's a nonprofit.
But it's still a
model that you had
to develop and refine and find a
product market fit it and scale
it.
It's a very
professional approach.
Could be one of the
secrets, maybe, of scaling
this-- that it's run
by professionals?
JOHN WOOD: I think that's
a really key thing.
In our case, we've
also layered in--
and we have great support on
this from the Gates Foundation,
from Bill and Melinda's
foundation-- that we've also
set up a research monitoring
and evaluation arm.
Because we don't want to just
put in a literacy program
or put in a long-term education
program for girls and hope
it works, right?
The whole idea that in God we
trust, all others bring data--
we do that.
We measure reading scores.
I was in India two
weeks ago and saw
the second graders
in our schools
were reading at 37
words per minute,
whereas in the
average government
school that we're
not engaged in,
that number is 14
words per minute.
We track comprehension levels.
We track how many books
are being taken out
of the libraries.
We track how many of the girls
in our girl's education program
are attending our life skills
courses, how many of them
are bringing their parents along
so their parents feel engaged.
So we're kind of data-driven
geeks at Room to Read.
And I think that data collection
and that evidence-based
learning permeates
everything we do
so we can find out
where are we strong,
and let's replicate that
and share it out across all
the country we're working in.
Let's also find out and admit
where we're not doing so well,
and then go try
to figure out why.
What's keeping those
numbers from being
as good as we want them to be,
and how does the program design
then need to evolve so that
those numbers get better
over time?
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Fascinating.
Do you have examples of maybe
something that didn't work
and then you stopped
it, and then maybe
something that's surprising
and worked better than you ever
thought based on the data?
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
I once asked that question
to Dr. Cory Heyman,
who at the time was our director
of programs-- one of the most
brilliant people I know.
And every time he talks to
me, I feel like I get smarter.
And I asked him that once.
I said, well, give me
an example of this.
So it's actually Cory's example.
But he was telling
me in our early days
in Zambia, where
80% plus of girls
don't make it past grade
six, we had all these girls
in our program.
And the dropout rate
wasn't ridiculously high,
but it was high enough
compared to other countries.
We said, let's go study.
Why are girls dropping out
of our program in grade seven
or grade eight or grade nine?
And so they did a survey,
and they basically
tried to find out what reasons.
Two of the top three reasons
girls were dropping out
of school were pregnancy
and teenage marriage.
And the more the local
teams studied that,
the more they realized
that bringing the girls
into the program at age 12
or 13 might be too late.
The bad habits may have
already been formed.
So they made a decision
to move the entry age
into the program up
by two to three years
so the girls would
come in earlier
and be able to take
part in our life skills
programs, which teach things
like the benefits of delaying
marriage, contraception,
their rights over their body--
things like that.
In addition to the
academics, we're
also teaching the
girls the life skills
they'll need to negotiate key
decisions they'll have to make.
A lot it's done in partnership
with the tech community.
So Goldman Sachs has
underwritten a program
to teach entrepreneurship.
The MetLife foundation
is underwriting a program
to teach the girls
financial literacy.
And that's a key part of
Room to Read's success
is partnership with
the corporate world.
We're very pro-capitalist.
Our belief is that if we
can partner with the world's
leading firm, we can just get
a lot more done in partnership
and get a lot more
done working together.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
It's fascinating to see
how you scaled this
from this core idea.
And like you said, it's almost
life coaching that you offer,
really.
You change deeply ingrained
habits and notions.
You mentioned a scale.
And in the preparation, I
looked at some of the numbers.
It's mind-blowing.
So talk about where
you stand today
and how big this whole
thing has become.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
The numbers are really great.
They've got to get higher.
You've got to stay humble,
you've got to stay hungry.
We were happy with
where we are, but we're
well aware that there's
tens of millions
of kids who have never
heard of Room to Read.
And every day we lose is
a day we can't get back.
So when I tell our results, I
try to also say with humility,
we've got a long,
long way to go.
But two weeks ago,
we were in India.
We celebrated a
couple of milestones.
One is over 50,000 young
women have taken part in,
are enrolled in,
or have graduated
from our long-term
girl's education program.
The number is actually 54,000.
It's pretty amazing.
Every time we raise 300
Swiss francs, one more girl
can be in the
program for one more
year, so it's a very
inexpensive model of change.
We celebrated our
20,000 community
reached by our literacy
and our library programs.
That means over 18 million
books in the hands of kids.
That means, right now,
by the end of 2017,
we should have about
12.5 million students
in 15 countries benefiting
from our programs,
and that number will go to
at least 15 million by 2020.
But if I was a
betting man, I'd bet
we'll be even higher than that.
The official number
is 15 million,
but I have faith we're
going to get to reach
even more kids than that.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
And then I saw also
your revenue numbers
are impressive.
What's the total revenues?
JOHN WOOD: We bring in
about $50 million US a year,
and that's pure
philanthropic capital.
Five zero-- $50 million.
And a lot of it is done
through that project adoption
model, where people
will say, well
gosh, we had a family
in Aspen, Colorado
whose daughter was
getting married.
And as a wedding gift, they
funded a new school literacy
program in Cambodia, and
then sent their daughter
Lauren and her husband
Matt on a surprise trip
to go actually see it and
be there for the unveiling.
And so while we do
raise a lot of money,
I think the important
thing to recognize
is a lot of it is
very bottoms up.
So even things like
Giving Week at Google--
people have been super
supportive of us.
And as big as we get, we try
to always remind ourselves
that even one person
can make a difference.
And that's why I think the
girl's education program has
grown as much as it has,
because a lot of that money
is coming from people
who literally just say,
well, I don't have
a huge amount.
But if I give $900 US, three
girls go to school for a year.
But we're happy
with where we are,
but I keep stressing
the fact that we're
competing against
forces out there
that are fairly nefarious.
I mean, everything from
poverty, to apathy, to misogyny,
to bigger things like
ISIS and al-Qaeda,
who want to reach kids with
negativity in their lives.
And I believe that education
is the ultimate positive thing,
so it's what drives
us and drives
our entire board
and our leadership
team and our front line staff
to keep working hard to say,
don't ever get complacent.
We got to reach every
kid who needs us.
And until we've done
that, there's no resting.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Fascinating.
When I did the research, I
looked a bit on your website,
and you have, I think, a
2020 plan, 25 year plan.
So you really run this
like a business like Google
or a startup that is
ambitious and spells out
the vision in this [INAUDIBLE].
It's really fascinating.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
And part of that is also
admitting where you're weak.
Because it's one thing
to be transparent
when you're talking about all
the wonderful things you're
doing and all the
successes you've had.
But we also have to really,
I think, analyze and go
collect data to say,
where can we get better?
And so we learned in 2004--
you and I were talking earlier
about our local language
publishing initiative.
In 2004, we did a
study of students
who are using our
libraries to ask them,
what would cause you to
use libraries more often?
And we give them
multiple choice options.
They could check as many boxes
they want-- open at nights,
open on weekends,
whatever it would be.
But the number one
answer kids gave us--
54% wanted more books
in their mother tongue--
in this case, Nepalese
and Vietnamese.
Which sounds obvious--
of course kids
want books in their
mother tongue.
But the issue is that
the for-profit publishers
don't publish books in
languages spoken by poor people.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Because it's
not an interesting business.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
There's no margin there.
When I was at Microsoft, we
would localize all the software
first in the French,
German-- the languages spoken
by wealthy people.
And then you might eventually
get to Lao or Uzbek Setswana,
or you may never get there.
Kids' books is even worse,
because kids' books don't
have the same scale economy
of what software has-- how
quickly software can spread.
So the problem that we face
is that there's really not
like a Dr. Seuss or a Tintin
in these poor countries,
so we decided to
basically start training
local authors and
local artists to be
the first in their generation to
publish children's literature.
And what we did starting
in 2004 in Nepal
is we found local authors
and local artists.
We asked them to
create original content
so kids would see books
that were relevant to them.
So the kids in Cambodia
would see houses on stilts,
and the kids in Nepal would see
yaks and mountains and things
like that.
And we started small.
We started with 10
titles in Nepal in 2004.
But I'm proud to say
we've now created
over 1,300 original titles.
99% of them are local
authors and local artists
and local editors.
We print locally to try to help
create employment and create
economic opportunities for
those authors and artists
to keep having income
from publishing.
And we were given the UNESCO
Confucius Prize for Literacy
recognizing that we
weren't just taking
books like "Pippi
Longstocking" or "Heidi"
and translating them into Khmer,
and then the kids in Cambodia
are confused--
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Create
something locally, right?
JOHN WOOD: Create
something locally
that kids can relate to.
And if people go
to roomtoread.org,
one of the fun things
about our website
is actually going and seeing
the photographs of the books
that kids are actually
reading in our libraries
in our schools.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
And you even said--
I think I read somewhere
you are the biggest book
publisher in the world.
Is this true, or
one of the biggest?
JOHN WOOD: Well,
it's a joke I made
that we're the biggest
children's publisher you've
never heard of.
Like many of my jokes,
it's not that funny.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: It
was moderately funny
JOHN WOOD: But we
publish in languages
that our kids don't
speak in Switzerland
or in Hong Kong, where I live.
We're publishing in Zulu,
Setswana, Xhosa, Sinholese,
Tamil, Lao.
We've done a couple
of new languages
in the last couple of years.
We've added in Swahili,
which, as a person who's
spent a long time in East
Africa, I'm very excited about.
But what I'm most proud
about with that is,
again, it's not
well-meaning foreigners
coming in with a solution.
In Tanzania, those
books in Swahili
have Tanzanian authors and
Tanzanian artists behind them.
And I got to tell you,
they're the proudest people
in the world.
Because when you have a really
motivated 25, 26-year-old
who realizes that in their
brain and in their talent
lies a possible solution to
poverty in their country,
they're some of the most
motivated people I've ever met.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
That's fascinating, yeah.
That's so inspiring.
So I guess I don't even have
to ask you this question,
but did you ever regret
leaving Microsoft then?
JOHN WOOD: The
only thing I regret
is that I used to have this
magic credit card where I never
saw the bill, and I just
could just spend money and not
have to care.
It just went to an
accountant somewhere.
But no.
I mean, look, there's
sacrifices involved
for anybody who does this
social sector for a living.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Which sacrifices did you
take personally?
JOHN WOOD: Well, I
think financially.
I worked for no salary
for three years.
Room to Read issues
stock options
that will pay off
karmically in the afterlife.
I mean, you give up.
I'm 53 years old, and
I'm still renting.
I don't own a home.
I don't know that I
ever will own a home.
That's a very small
sacrifice to make,
though, compared to
the parents I've met,
where they literally
will eat one meal a day
and save that extra money to
be able to buy their child
clothing or medicine.
So the sacrifices we make
are very, very minor.
Do I regret it?
Not at all.
Some of the happiest
days of my life
have been those days when I'm
in villages that Room to Read
helps.
And not just meeting the
students, which is fun,
but also meaning
that grandmother who
says, I can die now that I
know my granddaughter is going
to get through school,
meeting that farmer in Nepal
who had brought a hundred
pound bag of grain
to the community celebration,
because they were doing a grain
drive where any
farmer could donate
grain that would be sold off
and that money would be used
to help improve the school.
The stories I've
gotten to here--
and if people have not
read my first book,
there's a lot of stories.
That book was
titled "I'm Leaving
Microsoft to Change the
World," which is, I know,
a grandiose title.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: But it is.
It's true.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
It just tells the
story, I think,
about how any of us who are
committed and passionate
about education can just
make a humongous difference.
And to me, that's the
ultimate question in life--
what's your legacy going to
be when you're 70 or 75 or 80,
and you're sitting there in
your rocking chair looking back
on your life?
And you're going to
ask, what did I do?
What did I create?
I would never judge anybody
by their own legacy.
But I do look at myself
in the mirror and ask,
what's my legacy, and what's
this organization's legacy
going to be?
And I damn well want
that legacy to be
as huge and as impactful and
as long-lasting as possible.
And if we don't
do that, I'll just
consider it to be
completely suboptimal,
because this is the most
important issue in the world--
education for the
poorest of the poor.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Two questions
about this conviction part,
because it's fascinating.
It really comes through
how much it means to you.
In that moment when you came
back with the books and you
got that feedback, and then when
you decided to leave Microsoft,
how clear was that
for you to leave?
did you have doubts?
I'm sure you had some doubts.
Was it like 90-10, 80-20?
Was it 50-50-- first question.
Second question--
throughout the years,
did you ever doubt the decision?
I'm sure there were
challenges on the way.
So how did you deal with
those doubts if you had any?
JOHN WOOD: Well, I think
leaving Microsoft-- yes, it
was very intimidating for me.
I remember going into my
boss's office one day,
and I had been working up my
courage for a couple of days.
And it was 8:30 in the morning,
and I walked into his office.
And I said, I'm going
to tell you something
you don't want to hear.
And then I'm going
to leave for the day,
and then you can
respond tomorrow.
And he looked at me
like I was crazy.
I go, I quit.
This doesn't work
for me anymore.
And he said, but, but,
then I said, no no no.
We're not talking
about this today.
I'm leaving for the day.
And I literally went
out the building
and went to a little
tea shop in Beijing
and pulled out my journal,
and I wrote like, holy crap,
I did it.
I threw myself out
of the airplane.
Now I got to hope the
parachute deploys.
It was nerve-racking
in a sense, because I
think in the Western world,
so much of the way people
perceive us is what
we do for a job.
The first thing someone
asks you at a dinner party--
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
It's identity, right?
JOHN WOOD: Right.
What do you do?
And I was going from saying
Microsoft, greater China, blah,
blah, blah, to being
like, I deliver books
on the back of yaks in
rural Himalayan villages.
It was an instant
loss of status.
That was big.
But then the second part of
your question was about--
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
Through over the years.
Was it like--
JOHN WOOD: The regret?
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Did you
ever look back-- exactly.
JOHN WOOD: I think 2000
was a horrible time
to launch a charity.
The tech bubble burst.
My own savings went way down.
People had reasons not to give.
Then in America, where we
were based, 9/11 hit in 2001,
and America became this very
much more xenophobic place
then.
And it was rough the
first couple of years.
Our first year, I think
we raised $35,000.
Our second year, we
raised about $165,000.
And although a little bit
of money goes a long way,
that's way too little.
So the frustration
was-- and I remember
being with our founding team,
and I wrote on our whiteboard,
I wrote TBIT.
And those letters stood
for Too Big To Ignore.
I said, one day,
we just got to keep
grinding this out school by
school, village by village,
girl scholar by girl scholar.
And one day, our numbers
will be big enough
that the world will not
be able to ignore us.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
And when was that day?
JOHN WOOD: That was 2001, 2002,
during the very early years.
But we're very fortunate that
not only did Silicon Valley
and a lot of the tech
community get behind us,
but also Goldman Sachs
and Credit Suisse
and a lot of the
banking community
and a lot of the finance
community got behind us.
Because we went to the finance
community and the banking
community and said,
here's the ROI.
When you put $300 in and a
girl goes to school for a year,
her eventual wages
will increased
by 20% per additional
year of schooling.
So give a girl six additional
years of schooling,
her eventual wages
will double or triple.
When a woman makes an extra
dollar in the developing world,
she tends to spend 90%
of it on the family.
Women are more enlightened
than we men are about how
we spend the marginal dollar.
They spend it on food, shelter,
clothing, education, medicine.
So the ROI, I think,
was really, really clear
to say, if you can actually
put, let's say, $1,800 in,
and a girl goes to school
for six additional years
and is the first in her
family to ever finish
secondary school--
Don Valentine, the founder
of Sequoia Capital,
and I explained it to him--
he said this is the biggest
no-brainer in philanthropy.
And his daughter Hillary
had been involved,
but she said you got
to pitch to my dad.
And if my dad
agrees, then you're
going to get the family
behind it in a bigger way.
And Don Valentine-- when I
published my second book,
he put a blurb on it for me.
And here's a guy--
Sequoia-- they've
invested in everything.
And he wrote, Room to Read is
the best long-term investment
I have ever made.
And that was very humbling.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: So
actually, in a sense,
you had success quite
early on in a sense.
But the validation
and the scaling moment
came quite early, so congrats.
JOHN WOOD: It did, but I
think for our founding team,
we looked at it.
And it was just never
going to be enough,
because you keep thinking about
all the villages you haven't
reached.
So we did start to reach
some significant scale.
But we opened our
5,000th library in 2007,
and that was our
first seven years.
And then we got an invitation
from the Clinton Global
Initiative to come up with
a big, audacious goal.
So basically, Erin,
my co-founder--
we were like, let's go
from 5,000 to 10,000
and do that in three years.
And so we did our first capital
campaign, and got to that.
And now we're at 20,000
communities impacted,
but I'm looking forward to
the day I can tell you there's
100,000 communities.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Talk
about the future, actually.
Where is this going to be
in five years, in 10 years?
What are your plans?
JOHN WOOD: Well, the most
immediate thing for us
is that we're launching it.
Just right now, I'm
heading off from Zurich.
I'll be going to Amman.
We're launching Room To Read in
Jordan, which we're very, very
excited about, because Jordan
has been a country that's
been very accepting of
refugees, certainly more
so than my own homeland.
The United States has
not been as welcoming
to Syrian refugees.
Over two million
refugees in Jordan--
it's put an incredible strain
on the school system there.
So with support from the
Dubai Cares Foundation--
Dubai Cares has a program
called Reading Nation--
we're launching our first
Arabic language children's book
publishing program.
We're doing our first Arabic
language early readers.
These are mostly
Jordanian and some Syrians
involved with doing this
next generation of books.
We're doing 20 original titles,
30,000 copies of each book.
Every primary school
in the entire country
at the invitation of
the Jordanian ministry
will now have these books.
And for us, it's
our 25th language.
We also are looking potentially
at bringing a program
into Lebanon.
Lebanon has also a huge
number of refugees.
If you look out five
years, 10 years--
by the end of this
year, we're going
to have reached about
12.5 million children.
If you look out 10
years-- let's just
say if we could go from reaching
about 1 million students a year
today to reaching 2
million students a year,
and then you did
that over a decade,
you would add 20 million
additional students,
and you'd be at well
over 30 million.
Could we do that?
I know our team is good
enough they could do that.
The gating question
becomes the funding.
Can you get enough
funding coming in
so that those teams
are well resourced?
Because we do not want to be
in the business of saying no.
If a government says
to us-- and this
happens in India, where 35% of
the world's illiterate people
live in India.
And my challenge to the Indian
tech community and business
community is, you're
doing really, really well,
but don't forget that
there's tens of millions
of our little
brothers and sisters
out there who are
not getting educated.
And I think for us, the path
to scale-- a lot of that
can pass through India.
If we could just completely
blow out our work in India,
there's no shortage of kids
whose lives could be changed.
And so I look forward.
I was in India two weeks
ago, and our local team--
Sourav, our country
director who is amazing,
told me that we've already
reached over 3 million students
in India.
But I would love to see the
day where we're at 10 million,
15 million, 20 million in India.
Because that in and of itself--
so much of the future
can be changed for India,
but we've got to
reach those kids who
otherwise are overlooked.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: You
mentioned tech already
a couple of times--
investors, the tech community.
What role does tech
actually play in your model
in the initiative?
JOHN WOOD: Yeah, I think there's
two ways for a group like Room
to Read to look at tech.
Number one is, what
does tech enable
us to do just in terms of
running efficient operations?
What does tech allow us to
in keeping a global workforce
of 1,500 volunteers
across 20 plus countries,
15,000 volunteers--
how do we stay connected?
And so we have
great partnerships.
Lenovo gives us free ThinkPads
to keep our overhead low.
Salesforce has given
us free storage
from the very beginning.
Marc Benioff is totally
walking the walk
when he talks about being
a good corporate citizen.
Then there's how do
you use technology
in actually deploying
the education programs?
And we've been a little bit
loath to go too far too fast
in that direction,
because there's
an old saying of putting the
cart in front of the horse.
And I think until a child
achieves early grade literacy--
can read at 40 words
plus per minute,
can comprehend what
they're reading--
technology can't do a
lot of good for them.
Yeah, they can play games.
But if you give an
illiterate child
a tablet that doesn't have any
local language content on it,
it's just not going
to do that much good.
What those kids need
more is trained teachers.
They need local language books.
Books can be maligned.
I think books are wonderful.
Books are a
single-purpose device.
There's nothing beeping
at you or tweeting at you
or telling you there's a
Facebook update that so-and-so
posted their daughter's
prom pictures,
and it distracts
you from reading.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: It
goes deeper, longer.
It's a longer commitment.
JOHN WOOD: Yeah.
You get totally engaged in it.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ:
So thank you so much.
We heard a lot of great stuff.
We actually have a
little surprise now.
We have actually a
video of a person
that went through your program.
And actually, it's a
fascinating human story
about how much of a difference
you made for that person.
So why don't we quickly
look at a video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Wonderful.
And I love the reference
to Google Maps,
because I've worked on
Google Maps for seven years.
So this was a wonderful,
touching story of Saluom
out of Cambodia,
and a second part
of the surprise-- we actually
have Saluom with us today here.
So I would love to welcome
here on stage with us.
It's just a pleasure.
JOHN WOOD: Hello, Saluom.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Thank
you so much for coming.
It's wonderful that
you join us here.
Saluom, tell us
a little bit more
how this initiative Room
to Read impacted your life?
SALUOM LAK: The
first thing, I would
like to say good afternoon
to everyone in coming here.
If you ask me what is
the influence of Room
to Read on my life--
I think that there
are many thing
that it impacts on my life.
But the first one, I would
like to introduce myself
to all of you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Saluom Lak.
I'm from [INAUDIBLE]
of Cambodia.
I have been graduated
from high school in 2013,
and I also just graduated
from the Royal University
of Phnom Penh with my
major in sociology.
And I'm currently now
a training teacher
at National Institute
of Education.
It is the best
school in Cambodia.
I also passed an exam to be a
high school teacher that only 3
of 75 students from
[INAUDIBLE] can pass.
I'm so proud of this result.
JOHN WOOD: You should be.
SPEAKER 1: My parents very
happy that they could not
sleep that night when
the result was out.
It's not only because I got
a position as a high school
teacher, but also because I
am the first one in my family
to study at the University.
And also, I am the
first in my village
to become a qualified
high school teacher.
I grew up in a family of eight.
My parent and our
family has always
living in the
difficult situation,
but I believe that
I'm be able to provide
my family with better
living in the future
through my education.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: Perfect.
When have you first
met, both of you?
JOHN WOOD: Today.
Today.
It's our first time meeting.
And actually, you
were also saying
you are the first
person from your village
to ever travel to Europe.
SALUOM LAK: I'm the first
person that traveling to Europe,
and the first person that
can travel by airplane.
It is many experience for me.
JOHN WOOD: And it's always
one of the highlights for me.
Because when I
meet our graduates,
quite often when you see some
of these young women entering
the program in grade 6 or grade
7, they're not very confident.
They're afraid of their future.
And one of the thing's that's
really critical to Room
to Read's success of our
girl's education program--
it's not an academic
scholarship.
Yes, we're doing things like
paying school fees and exam
fees for those who
can't afford it.
But the most important
parts of the program
are really what we
surround the girls
with-- that they have
social mobilizers,
strong local women who
check in on a regular basis.
We have after school
tutoring available,
so if they need help on their
math exam or their science
exam, they have tutoring.
And then we have the
life skills course,
which I mentioned earlier,
which teaches these young women
the skills they'll need to
negotiate those key life
decisions.
And obviously, in
Saluom's case, that even
involves learning
about Google Maps
and being able to figure
out how to use Google Maps.
So that's a win-win
for the world.
RAPHAEL LEITERITZ: It
makes me personally happy.
Thank you so much.
It's wonderful.
Well, thank you so
much both for coming.
Such an inspiring story, Saluom.
Thank you so much.
And really, congrats,
and you can be
so proud of what you achieved.
And John, same for you.
You can be incredibly proud
of what you kicked off here
and what you have done
to improve the world.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you.
JOHN WOOD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]